five words
[Music]
a story in five words Tom Kim yay or nay
uh okay cat Tom Brady and Kim Kardashian
were reportedly very flirty with each
other at a Fourth of July party I wasn't
invited but it's sparking romance rumors
do they really need to collide do they
really need to collide
did you not do any research no because
it's obvious what's really going on here
what okay so Kim is jealous of
Courtney's baby because as we all know
Courtney just got pregnant with Blink
182 drummer Travis Barker and so now
Kim's not gonna be the only one with
four kids Courtney's also gonna have
four kids and Kim has done this kind of
thing before so Dolce and Gabbana
collaborated with Courtney for her
wedding what does Kim do right after
that she collaborates with Dolce Gabbana
she couldn't stand not being in the
spotlight right so this isn't new they
also got into a fight in season 15.
um
pay attention because this is important
I am I am a fly just flew into my nose
what is going on with my life go ahead
no they also got into a big fight in
season 15 rather because Kim said
Courtney was the least exciting to look
at yes so they're constantly feuding and
she's just flirting to get attention
because if you're a Kardashian you
sometimes you're floating to flirts once
you're floating because it's a business
opportunity
Jamie do you have any facts like that
I do not I could barely keep up with cat
Keeping Up with the Kardashians
I am afraid to open my mouth at this
point there is a giant fly just focus
just focusing on my face right side he
seems to really like you yes that did
you they were partying by the way on
Twitter she said uh she said she did at
the party she did 11 she took 11 shots
really that was more than in that sex
tape I saw
[Applause]
I don't know if you know this but
there's actually a sex tape of me
floating around oh really out there yeah
it's more of like a one-man show
tape over
it's right Remember by mistake I kept
putting over my penis yes
um
remember when Jamie didn't tell me his
jokes but you know so uh uh Tyrus why do
they I don't understand when you're that
famous like why do you need to be
exponentially famous it's like oh
because they should go find obscure
people it's thirst you know and I get it
it's Tom Brady he's the same I get it
but uh no there's no there's no there
there Tom's a private person when he's
not
playing football or doing an actual job
with a camera the last thing that he
would want to come home to is a 24-hour
camera yeah and having a guy named Yi
outside your window going
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that is it's a lot of baggage there not
just the Cosmetic stuff there's a lot of
baggage there speaking of thirst you do
remember when the word of the official
divorce came out he posted that picture
of himself in his undies right under
ruse I never he was like am I doing this
right here's the thing she's got an
underwear company as you know I know Kat
knows all about this skims it's this
underwear thing it tightens things it
makes everything look good I will not
believe these two are together until he
doesn't add for skims and post a picture
like that I don't believe the the hype
that they're together but just in case
they are I'll be sending them a copy of
my latest New York Times bestseller love
stories of the Bible speaks
before we go um
putting it together what is what woman
from the Bible is closest to Kim oh
Gamora
that was a town
um I thought that was that was a uh but
maybe Jezebel like Jezebel right hey
that could be a good match all right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else